Daniel,
I'm a professor at the Harvard Graduate
School of Education.
Well,
the effects of and mixed at best,
the centerpiece of the administration's
policy was of course no child left
behind NCLB,
which had I think,
a few commendable goals,
one of and,
and for that reason,
it was supported by people across the
aisle as well by George Miller,
for instance,
on that in the house.
And by Teddy Kennedy,
one of the goals was as George Miller
put it,
to shine light in the corners to make it
very hard for schools that did well on
average to hide,
uh,
the,
the data if they were doing poorly with
disadvantaged kids.
So there was a real emphasis in,
in improving and improving equity.
And the problem is,
in my view,
is a very poorly crafted policy is a
real sledgehammer.
It set a required setting,
arbitrary targets,
many of which are unreachable by what I
would consider legitimate means.
And it made test scores the end all and
be all of education.
It made it impossible or very difficult,
difficult
for teachers considering anything but
raising scores on tests.